You say, okay, so fine,
you docked a little responsibility for
yourself and you can sleep with a clean
conscience.
What happens if you dropped it full
responsibility for yourself and then for
your family? Lots of the people
who are coming to talk to me say,
now I've been really trying to put my
family together. I have made that a goal.
I'm trying to heal my family and
bring it together and it's working.
So here's a story. I love this
story, man. It just killed me.
I was in la at the Orpheum and you know,
it's rough downtown in la at places
around the Orpheum too. And Tammy and I,
my wife, because she's traveling with
me and is a big help by the way. Um,
we're wandering around downtown La
that morning after the talk and, uh,
we're walking down the street
and we were on streets.
We probably shouldn't have been on,
but in any case,
because what the hell do we
know being stupid Canadians?
And so we're walking down the street
and this car pulled up beside us and his
kid hopped out and he's good looking
Latino Kid, 2021, something like that.
He jumped over and he said, uh, he's all
excited. He said, are you Dr. Peterson?
I said, yeah, yeah. And he said, I'm
really, really happy to meet you. Um,
I've been watching your lectures
for like a year and a half and, uh,
I've been trying to put my life
together and it's really working.
I'm really doing way better. I really want
it to thank you. And so it's lovely a,
when you're walking down and kind of rough
area and somebody pulls up beside you
and they jump out of the car to tell
you how much better their life is,
that's a pretty good morning. And so,
but then that is, no, that happened.
He ran back to his car. He said,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
He went back to his car and he got out
his dad and they came over together and
his dad was just smiling away,
like a real smile, you know?
And so as the kid and they had their
arms around each other and they said,
look like we've really been working on
our relationship for the last year and a
half and it's going just great
and we want to thank you.
And the father said something like,
I'm really happy that you got my
son back to me. It's like, yes,
that's what this bloody tour
has been like. It's great.
And everybody that's coming
to these talks, that's what
they're trying to do now.
I've got 3000 people in each audience
and what they're trying to do is figure
out how can I take maximal
responsibility for my own life?
How can I imbue it with the meaning
that helps me with Stan tragedy and
suffering?
How can I be a better person and wouldn't
it be great if that was of optimal
benefit to my family and the community?
You get very emotional about this. Well,
it's something Joe Jesus, I seem like
150,000 people in the last two months,
you know,
and this is what it's well,
you'll have a chance to talk
to Reuben about this too.
This is what it's been like. It's
so positive. I can't believe it.
And it's just one person after
another saying like, look, I was,
I was having a rough time.
I'm really happy that I've
been encountering what
you've been talking about.
I've really been trying to put things
together and it's really helping.
Yeah, Ruben was pretty blown away by
it. We had a long conversation about it,
about,
he just feels like there's some crazy
movement going on at something's changing
in the world because of this.
This new avenue of learning and
developing is opening up for these people.
Well, well I know, I've been thinking
about that too because you know,
like I said at the beginning,
if you're surfing,
you don't want to take responsibility
for the wave. And so you know, I mean,
first of all,
a lot of what I've been telling people
are things that I've gleaned from the
clinical leader and the
psychological literature.
It's not like I'm coming up with
this of my own accord, right?
I'm transmitting information that I've
learned from very, very wise people.
And so there's that.
But also we don't want to underestimate
the utility of the technology, right?
Because we have this long form technology
now and it's enabling us to have this
discussion and so we can get deeper
into things publicly and socially.
Then we were able to
before and I see this,
I see this as a manifestation of that and,
and as an,
and I'm hoping too that maybe,
maybe what's happening cause we were
going to have a lot of adaptation to do in
the next 20 years as things change so
rapidly we can hardly comprehend it and
hopefully the way we're going to be
able to manage that is to think and
hopefully these long form discussions
will provide the political or provide the
public forum for us to actually think,
to actually engage at a deep enough level.
So we'll be able to master
the transformations. And
I think that's possible.
I mean,
part of the reason that I wrote this
book and well part of the reason that I'd
be doing what I've been doing for the
last 30 years is because I really have
believed since 1985 something like that,
that the way out of
political polarization,
the way out of the excesses of the right
and the left is through the individual.
I think the west got that right.
The fundamental unit of measurement is
the individual and the fundamental task
of the individual is to engage in this
process of humble self improvement.
I believe that's the case and that's
where the meaning is and that's where the
responsibility is.
And I think,
and I'm hoping that if enough
people in the west and then,
and then have the rest of
the world for that matter,
but we're very polarized
in the west right now.
If enough people take responsibility for
getting their individual lives together,
then we'll get wise enough so we
won't let this process of political
polarization put us back to the same
places that we went so many times in the
20th century. I don't see another
antidote for it. It's not political.
It's ethical.